direction maintenant saint malo en
bretagne où des habitants de la ville
est une association ont finalement
décidé de porter plainte contre
l'entreprise thilmakha gros après des
années à alerter les autorités
ils se plaignent d'odeurs nauséabondes
dégagées par cette usine bongrain et
mini google on au parquet estelle farges
ils sont douze habitants en colère avec
l'association osons ils ont décidé de
porter plainte contre thilmakha gros
propriété du groupe local roulier
l'usiné fabrique des farines animales et
des engrais mais depuis 2014
rien ne va plus les plaignants accusent
l'industriel de polluer l'air de saint
malo en rejetant de l'ammoniac
il n'y a aucune raison qu'une entreprise
décide de rejeter 12 13 15 fois plus
d'ammoniac qu'elle n'est autorisé à le
faire qui porte un problème de santé
publique
il n'y a aucune raison qu'elle décidé
qu'elle soit complètement laisser comme
ça de manière je vais pas dire un pli
parce que le problème n'est pas de punir
le problème il est d'obtenir le respect
de la réglementation des installations
classées
pascal nos vies qui fait partie des
plaignants
elle décrit notamment l'odeur des
émanations de lusine bas il ya deux
types de duisans sont des nuisances
vraiment qu'ils sont gênantes pour la
santé des toutes les irritations que je
vous décrivais puis à l'autre aspect il
ya aussi une odeur de sucré de patates
pour id
enfin de 20 des gens les qualifie de
façon différente suivant leur ressenti
mais une odeur très prégnante qui vient
sur une partie de la ville suite aux
productions de l'industriel pour hélène
de kristofo ces émanations entraîne des
pathologies médecin elle habite saint
malo depuis plusieurs années elle se
souvient d'avoir soigné les enfants
d'une famille qui habitait tout près de
t-mac agro sans succès j'ai conseillé à
la famille de déménager
comparons réputé parce que vraiment on
n'arrivait pas à bout du tout de toutes
ces pathologies respiratoires
ils ont déménagé son parti hors de sa
malheureuse dans un village pas très
loin et alors là ça a été fabuleux parce
que très rapidement les problèmes se
sont réglées les enfants retrouver un
état de santé normal ça ne les empêche
pas de faire des petites pathologies
hivernales comme tous les enfants mais
plus du tout ces pathologies quasiment
chronique que je voyais chez eux tout le
temps et il n'y a pas qu'à l'extérieur
que les nuisances se font ressentir
catherine habite saint malo depuis trois
ans elle dit subir des désagréments au
sein même de son appartement raconter
comment ce que vous êtes en bas quitté
palatinat qui est donc en fait
pardé poussière qui se dépose
dans l'appartement sur les carreaux
beaucoup aussi et surtout par les odeurs
les odeurs qui sont vraiment très fort
très très forte et qui envahissent
complètement l'appartement en portant la
faire devant la justice les douze
habitants et l'association espère que
l'entreprise se mettent aux normes
sollicité par rt france qui m'a kagoro
affirme travaillait en étroite
concertation avec les autorités
en attendant le tribunal de saint-malo
rendra son jugement le 2 juillet
prochain